you know we've done some videos reacting
to uh me giving my reviews of some hit
rap songs some joints that are truly if
i could just say
fire uh songs that when you listen to
them they make you
as the kids might say make you want to
cut a rug even do the hokey pokey
but today i want to switch it up a
little bit i happen to see an article
about a pop song
that's lighting up the charts a huge hit
it's number one
smash hit everyone's listening to it
everyone's talking about it
they're not talking about it to me
personally because i'm you know
a loser but i hear them when i'm when
i'm sulking alone by myself in the
corner
i hear people talking about it so it's a
big deal it's a song by a girl named
olivia rodrigo and it's called driver's
license wikipedia tells me that olivia
rodrigo
is an american actress and singer who's
known for her roles as paige
ulvera on the disney channel series
bizardvark what sounds like a medical
condition i have no idea what bisardvark
is i you know i'm just
i'm i am so many levels of out of touch
that even when you start i don't i don't
recognize the name and you start
explaining it to me by telling me
oh they're on this tv show i i don't
know what that is either oh you know
that's the show
this other person is on this other show
over here i don't know what that is oh
they're
they're on this tv i don't know what a
tv is i i don't i don't
we sit around a a radio the size of a
refrigerator at my house and we listen
to
you know murder mysteries at night
that's that's still where we're at 1932.
um but anyway this one is like i said i
what i'm told it's a big hit driver's
license is what it's called
let's take a listen and um just give it
a shot let's give this this song a shot
let's listen to
[Music]
driver's it last week just like
we always talked about cause you were so
excited for me to finally drive
up to your house but today i drove
through the suburbs
crying cause you weren't around
okay you know see i have to say it and
and this is why and i don't mean this
in a defensive way at all i but
this is why we need to rethink allowing
women to have driver's license
[Music]
and like i said i don't mean that
misogynistically just rethink driver's
license
and also voting but not not in a sexist
way at all
this girl is by her own admission
driving
and she's crying distraught and she's
going through the suburbs
we're talking residential areas and
she's speeding down the road hysterical
balling her eyes out
this is how somebody gets killed i mean
how many pedestrians have been
flattened like pancakes by teenage girls
driving around crying because their
boyfriend's broke up with them this is a
it's too many to count this is an
epidemic nobody talks about it
maybe the song is meant to raise
awareness of the problem i don't know
and also by the way what kind of
teenager is this depressed
after getting their driver's license
here you are already
aimlessly driving around forlorn stewing
on the fundamental misery of existence
and you just got your driver's license
last week
you know you shouldn't start doing that
until you're at least like 25.
i didn't have my first existential
crisis in a car
until this past month and i'm 34. so
she's uh way ahead of the curve
but let's uh let's let's keep listening
and you're probably with that blind girl
who always made me doubt
she's so much older than me she's
everything i'm insecure
about yet today i drove through the
summers
cause how could i ever love someone
else okay well how could you ever love
someone else
you're like 16 you'll love somebody else
45 seconds from now that's how it goes
at this age
this is why i i just i can't take the
relationship struggles of teenagers
seriously i just can't
because no relationship you have at this
age means anything
i got news for you none of it does even
your friends none of it means anything
it doesn't matter
i'm sorry no you guys didn't really love
each other you didn't you were
infatuated briefly
you're going to move on with your life
you won't even remember this person a
few years from now you won't remember
them
this is maybe my problem with with uh
with pop music is that
i can't listen to songs i can't listen
to somebody sing about heartbreak unless
they're old and grizzled
and ugly like me that's that's the oh i
can only take you seriously
on that subject if if you're like that
your marriage falls apart
you have kids you got a mortgage you got
back problems
you know you're out of shape you're
overweight how are you going to meet
somebody else
that i could take that seriously now
that's something that's worth a song or
two
you know you can be excused for even
driving through the suburbs weeping i'll
give you a couple of those
episodes too but uh not you know your
dumb boyfriend
you met in october broke up with you
after thanksgiving
give me a break snap out of it you're
embarrassing
[Music]
but yourself never felt this way
for no one
and i just can't imagine how you could
be so
okay
[Music]
you said forever now i drive alone past
your street
okay this is taking a dark turn actually
this is this is stalking you're driving
past this street
he's already broken up with you it's
over and you're driving past the street
how many times have you done this
this is they issue restraining orders
for this kind of thing olivia
this is why i'm concerned about you and
yeah i know he said forever i know he
did
he's a junior in high school forever for
him forever means like until fifth
period
okay now all right let's listen to this
girl complain
some more songs almost over i think i
miss you but
i kind of feel sorry for them cause
they'll never know you the way
that i do yet today i drove through the
suburbs
and pictured i was driving home to you
and i know we weren't
[Music]
okay
[Music]
you said forever now i drive alone past
your stream
okay yeah olivia listen i don't know
what to tell you uh this guy
said he loves you but he didn't and
here's the thing
here's here's the part you'll learn when
you get older you didn't really love him
either
so he did you a favor so you have to
understand the difference between
emotional codependence and actual love
and that you know that's a confusion
that explains much of pop music
and if not for that confusion we would
be spared almost the entire pop industry
love is not a feeling love is an act
it's a choice that you make
it's it's the giving of the self to
another it is it's sacrifice is what it
is
uh it's work thomas aquinas as i'm sure
you know he said that love is to will
the good of another to will
think about that to will the good of
another now this kind of love that you
two had
it was too self-involved it was too
self-interest interested to be true love
even now everything you're saying it's
all about how he made you
feel how you feel now
right you're singing about someone else
but all i hear is i i i me me me
your love of the other is really the
love of self
you haven't matured to the point it's
okay because you're still young you
haven't matured to the point of being
able to
truly reach out and love somebody else
that's the problem
and that's why i say that kids should
not be
dating or making pop music
you should date until you're 23. that's
the rule in my house
i've just decided you know right now at
this age you should be you could be
doing other things with your time
constructive things you could go um
you know go climb a tree build a diorama
start a kickball league sign up for one
of those
you know one of those programs where
they give you a pen pal in a foreign
country
these are the things you should be doing
at your age
okay good glad we could have this talk
uh now chin up sport it's gonna be okay
and nice job on the song you have a good
voice your mom and i are very proud of
you